ha tardado años en ponerse en marcha
pero la gran muralla verde parece que
por fin avanza el objetivo es plantar un
mosaico de 8000 kilómetros de árboles
praderas vegetación y plantas a todo lo
ancho de áfrica para luchar contra la
desertificación en la región del sahel y
proporcionar más seguridad alimentaria
tras una reunión con emanuel macrón al
margen de la cob el príncipe carlos
reiteró los objetivos del proyecto
green o la iniciativa de la gran muralla
verde ofrece una valiosa oportunidad
para restaurar la tierra los bosques y
la biodiversidad al tiempo que aborda el
impacto social económico y
medioambiental de la degradación de la
tierra el presidente francés también lo
calificó como una cuestión de seguridad
se trata de proyectos muy concretos que
proporcionan oportunidades económicas y
fuentes de trabajo que permiten
contrarrestar las terribles situaciones
que crean o bien migraciones repentinas
como es el caso de la región del lago
chad o bien situaciones de terrorismo
como es el caso del sahel emanuel macrón
dice que casi la mitad de los 19 mil
millones de dólares prometidos a
principios de año ya están en camino el
fundador de amazon jeff bezos ha
ofrecido otros mil millones de dólares
de su fundación y la unión europea
también comprometió ayuda
contribuiremos a diferentes pilares de
la gran muralla verde y eso es apoyar a
las comunidades locales mientras se
restaura el medio ambiente y se revierte
la pérdida de biodiversidad
y la gran muralla verde podría restaurar
100 millones de hectáreas de tierra
absorber 250 millones de toneladas
métricas de dióxido de carbono de la
atmósfera y crear 10 millones de puestos
de trabajo
[Música]